the earth is under attack and rather
than just completely obliterating us our
attackers have decided to simply cut our
planet in half is this an act of mercy
or the planetary equivalent of a slow
and painful death once the cutting
begins the devastating effects would be
felt all over the world which parts of
the globe would be safest how long would
life on earth be able to survive and
what would allow our planet to
regenerate itself naturally this is what
if and here's what would happen if the
earth was cut in half ripping earth in
half might not mean instantaneous death
for everyone on the planet instead some
people might be able to survive for a
short while if they happen to be in the
right place at the right time but as the
planet rapidly crumbles around them and
our social systems fall it wouldn't be
long before mass hysteria sets in how
long would it be before the remaining
humans start to turn on each other
it might start as just a bright light in
the sky something that you could quickly
shrug off but then as the ground beneath
you starts to shake violently and the
light keeps getting brighter you'd know
that something is seriously wrong as the
earth is methodically sliced in half
it's mantle and core would be exposed to
the vacuum of space causing massive
earthquakes that would be felt
everywhere on the planet at this point
the death toll would already be in the
millions you've seen the kind of
destruction that one powerful earthquake
can cause now imagine a bunch of them
taking place at the exact same time
those who are the furthest from the
split would have the best chance of
surviving the longest at least from the
initial earthquakes amidst all this
chaos people would be turning to their
phones and social media for answers but
it would be none to be found
frantic calls and texts would be
attempted but very few if any would make
it through because at this stage almost
all of the planets human inhabitants
seven and a half billion people would be
without electricity power grids would
fail as power stations sank into the
ground no power no social media with
their survival on the line people would
start looking out only for themselves in
larger urban centers being trampled
would become a serious possibility as
everyone scrambled for cover from
falling buildings at this point earth
could start to split along the tectonic
plates on both halves with a barrage of
natural and human-made materials being
cast off into space
[Music]
the slice would have also cut through
Earth's atmosphere exposing the planet
surface to the vacuum of space and
resulting in even more natural disasters
for anyone lucky enough to survive past
the first couple of days at this stage
the earth might try and use gravity to
help put a bandage on itself
as the two halves begin to get pulled
back towards one another you think that
this reunion would be good news for any
remaining survivors but things would
just get worse for a while you'd be
dodging the enormous chunks of matter
that would be shooting back and forth
between the two halves and then
eventually you'd experience astronomical
heat levels as the earth becomes nothing
more than two spinning orbs of molten
rock so yeah your chances of survival
aren't looking great in fact the whole
human race would almost certainly be
eliminated by this point the two rocks
that we used to call earth would
continue circling each other for
hundreds of thousands of years until
they'd finally collide to form a new
much smaller earth over the years it
would cool down microscopic life would
appear and eventually like hundreds of
millions of years later that life could
theoretically evolve into some new
version of the human species maybe one
day the new inheritors of the earth
would find a relic of our civilization
that would kick-start their
understanding of the history of the
planet but that's a topic for another
what-if
[Music]